con las tareas de rescate ya casi
completamente terminadas en todas las
regiones afectados afectadas y los
equipos de rescate internacionales que
llegaron la semana pasada para ayudar en
estas tareas marchándose del país las
autoridades turcas se centran ahora en
intentar remover los escombros de las
calles y de los edificios de ruidos e
intentar sacar los cuerpos ahí dentro
para evitar a que se propaguen
enfermedades en las zonas que están
ahora mismo no llenas pero donde sí que
hay mucha gente atrapada en campos de
refugiados improvisados creados por los
equipos de emergencia turcos esta este
terremoto que ocurrió hace algo más de
una semana en cuyo epicentro fue el
sudeste de Turquía pero que también
afectó el noreste si ha servido para que
Turquía recupere una relación muy dañada
con sus dos máximos enemigos históricos
y con los que tenía muy mala relación en
los últimos años se trata de Grecia y de
Armenia que ha mandado ayuda al país
sanatorio país rival geopolítico en la
región Grecia mandó desde el primer
momento equipos de rescate y ayuda
humanitaria y suministro de asuntos
exteriores viajó
a varias de las regiones afectadas
durante la semana pasada y se encontró
con su homólogo turcomeblut chakusulo
hace pocos hace pocas horas se ha
informado también que mañana llegará a
Turquía el ministro de asuntos
exteriores de Armenia arad missorianne
que será una de las primeras visitas
oficiales de un
miembro del gobierno armenio en varias
décadas recordemos que la semana pasada
por primera vez en 28 años se abrió la
frontera entre Armenia y Turquía cerrada
después en 1994 para que entrase desde
el lado armenio al lado Turco camiones
con ayuda humanitaria